looking to attack the paint go inside
establish the paint first that opens up
the inside outside game there's a team
guys is three-point shooting 37% but
right now they're able to get to the
basket to talk with up-and-under nice
move good attack there by the Red
Raiders and that's the first perimeter
shot today by either team is every field
goals come in the paint there's another
one I call ver underneath they were tops
in their league in fast-break points
this year with 15 a game none of that so
far today Culver for three guys try to
stay with him this time to kick out the
Francis for three gotta know Francis B
next offensive possession go back to
next and it just feels good soft bucket
boy that's the second time farmers had
that little spin off the glass this time
a chance for a three-point play and
problem may be got away with palming the
ball on that trip reporter from the
corner for Francis insides Maroney what
nice pass by Cole
Mooney hooks it in the paint to Owens
now Culver spins with a left hand got
McDonald on the bench lets his observe
over there like an assistant coach 1 to
7 on the game trying to find a way
voting for three yes he knows what he
signed up for when he came to Texas down
inside another block shot well the off
save this time Culver lives Owens
underneath inside another block shot the
off say this time Culver lives
Owens underneath excellent pass over the
top by Colvard hit really a beat Wright
State in their tournament title game at
12 degrees
speaking of a 3 there is Palmer live
once the year that they had you
understand why the excitement is there
the opportunity to advance do something
special for the program Mooney inside
everything working right now I'm 13 the
key is to get it under 10 right the 8
minute timeout now you give yourself a
chance but you got to play defense on
it's in and coach as you know as you see
Cobra go for the jump shots excellent
again defense by Texas Tech and Chris
beer the defense of the wizard really a
genius when it comes to this outside the
ball a lot polgár just feeling to tellus
25 their coverage I mean that is a
factor when you got the rim protector
like tarik Owens it is a difference
maker hey I called her sweet drive with
the
to rebounding sharp to this point has
written the main anchor in regard to
offense again the defensive stops are
gonna get you back in his ground loretta
he buries the jumper boy good movement
by Moretti there